i think what we're seeing for the first
time in
american history since america has
become like a worldwide cultural
institution in
starting like the early 1900s to some
extent is you're having
creative types fleeing these
liberal you know uh currently democratic
areas like la new york
and everyone's moving to red states to
austin to miami and a few others
this has never happened before where the
creativity
goes to the republican party and i don't
see how
you reverse that trend
what do you think comes after this
you've had a pretty good track record on
projecting all of this and i think you
have a good sense of the
general yeah one other one of the things
i am
i'm very optimistic about the future as
i said earlier in the show and in
general
and i when i'm optimistic i think
optimism has to be based on data
it's not just like everything's going to
be fine that is not the case there's
many cases where things
are not fine or they're only fine after
a very long period of time one of the
things i am
shocked and delighted by is how many
people on the right especially
conservatives
have seen the cops for what they are as
you know i'm an anarchist i have could
not have a worse opinion of the police
but they are understanding that the
police are not
their friends the police will follow any
law
that is being passed and when these
conservatives start defending the police
i asked them
how much money would it take you or
would it take for gretchen whitmer
to force you to lock an old person in
their home how much money would it take
for andrew cuomo to tell you to keep
someone away from their dying mother in
a hospital
so there it's a question of conscience
if you're going to just follow orders
if you're going to wave the basic
element of what separates us from the
lower animals
this sense of right and wrong and we see
it in
city after city after city the police
stand down
and the only people who are punished are
those who have
guns or those who are trying to defend
themselves or their communities
in fact we saw i believe it was in
portland uh when the attorney general
barr
sent in federal troops to guard the
courthouse he was the one
who was hauled before congress of having
to explain himself
how dare you send in troops to defend
federal property from being destroyed
it's a complete ask upside down world so
how much damage has to happen to these
cities before
something turns around either through
the people or
through better governance i suppose i
know that's not really your thing but
like
does portland have to just completely
become ground zero does seattle have to
collapse does new york city does
la san francisco like what like what
actually do you think has to happen at
the human level that gets people
going okay we gotta turn this around or
does everyone just have to flee the
cities
i think what we're seeing for the first
time in american history
since america has become like a
worldwide cultural institution
in starting like the early 1900s to some
extent is
you're having creative types fleeing
these liberal you know currently
democratic areas like la new york
and everyone's moving to red states to
austin to miami and a few others
this has never happened before where the
creativity
goes to the republican party and i don't
see how
you reverse that trend let's is the
question's gonna be
you know how did la get destroyed uh to
quote uh hemingway two ways gradually
and then suddenly
yeah uh i don't see a mechanism or even
a desire because when people complain in
these cities
about how how hard it is cuomo is a
great example of this
there was a press conference during this
whole covet thing and he was asked like
you know how do you you know you're
destroying these small businesses and
very flippantly
he was like well if i have to choose
between a lot of people dying and a lot
of
businesses going out of business it's
not an easy choice but it's also in one
sense not a hard choice
so there's not even like a sense of
handwringing
what have we done what has the cost been
because it's very useful
for the corporate media to not speak
about trade-offs thomas soule who i
adore and you're obviously a huge fan
uh says talks about instead of thinking
about like good or bad
at what costs and compared to what to
talk about costs
and benefits but they don't want to
think about costs and benefits they
don't want to think okay
this is a good thing but it's expensive
or this will help this group
but it's hurting these 10 other groups
it's more like it's the right thing to
do
don't ask any questions and like if
something is the right thing to do
in this short term that's certainly a
possibility what are going to be
the long-term cost and how do we fix it
they were tripping over themselves in
2008
to bail out the banks and now every
little business that i loved in new york
stores have been around since the 70s
the 50s they're boarded up the signs are
still there because they were proud this
is a family institution
they're gone and they're never coming
back and no one
cares do we have to jail some of these
people i mean is that like the end that
basically cuomo and whitmer and
newsome that it's very obvious there was
no science behind the lockdowns they
decided to destroy millions of lives i
killed the elderly i think that killed
literally kill the elderly in cuomo's
case and probably in whitmer's case well
no not probably let's talk about that
video i'm so interrupted but this video
went viral
there was this kid i i think he was 17
18 19
was in a nursing home and was beating up
elderly people
in their beds and posting it on social
media this went viral oh was that in
michigan i know
it was missing okay okay he was in those
homes
because by law it was mandated they're
going to be quarantining them
in these locations she so it's not maybe
she was killing person after person and
i have a uh
i'm sure you saw this on twitter if you
go to governors to gitmo dot com
i've got the t-shirts to that's my
answer to this problem right so
but really just one more thing i'm sorry
it's not going to change
until politicians have consequences on a
personal level
for their malfeasance and depravity i
don't know what that looks like
but it's certainly more than them
getting voted out of office this cannot
continue and i think they are pushing
america
in a very dangerous direction
brinksmanship is something that
very rarely has a happy ending well it's
like every day now
in california newsom's coming out and
we're giving you stuff
more money for you guys and it's like
wait a minute how do progressives
suddenly think giving us money is good
i thought the taxes are bad but it's all
the tax money you took from us in the
first place i mean
i know none of it really makes any sense
right but okay if voting amounts not
enough i mean really
what do you think either the jailing or
like what are we going to send them to
the phantom zone like what are we going
to do with these people
i'm okay with the phantom so but but
really like what's the real
thing because these people deserve none
of our respect or attention or money or
power or anything
i think something that's very you just
hit the nail on the head
one of the things that president trump
did very very well and there's a lot of
things he didn't do so well
is he demonstrated that these people
should not be treated with respect
but be treated with open brazen contempt
if you are telling me that i cannot hug
my child
if you are telling me that i can't see
my
mother breathe her last breath in this
hospital
this is not like well i've got one
opinion you've got another opinion let's
just kind of hash it out and agree
disagree
this is completely in my view beyond the
pale
and the time for conversation has ended
here there there's and the thing is
the republicans need to go on offense
instead of constantly having to
apologize and discuss
the hard left's idea du jour here's one
example everyone now
in this country who's politically minded
has an opinion
on whether we should defund the cops
right everyone talked about it everyone
most people are against it but everyone
discussed it why is no one discussing
ending birthright citizenship my
personal idea is to have a
using the second amendment and using the
logic of obamacare make
gun ownership mandatory the second
amendment says a well-regulated militia
which means
a militia of citizens who are regulated
who are informed and practiced
in the use of their firearms is
necessary for free people
so either you get a gun or you can't
vote things like this
now the new york times is going to freak
out the washington post is going to
freak out
don lemon is going to you know have a
meltdown on air
that's going to happen regardless yeah
ann coulter had this great quote where
she says
attention republicans if the new york
times isn't calling you racist
you're losing so the record for the
record huh called me a white supremacist
this week pretty good
really yeah well they asked andrew yang
why he goes on white supremacist shows
in effect
me they called it the dave rubin show
this is the reuben report
i couldn't even get them to retract that
i didn't even care about the white
supremacy part i was like ah
you know we've done that a million times
already but they got the name of the
show wrong they wouldn't even fix that
but you know what else is amazing so
it's an honor it's also it's also
amazing that you would ask a politician
why would you want to promote your views
on a place that has an audience
isn't it it's really funny because on
the one hand you have the maxine waters
types and i do like her antagonism and
aggression i'm not gonna lie
but she's saying if you see someone from
the trump administration at the gasoline
station at the mall
you go up to them and you say you're not
welcome here i would
you would expect them to if you are a
white supremacist if you're a homophobe
if you're an anti-semite all these
things which we know you are
right to come here and be like screw you
dave reuben
you're terrible your ideas are horrible
you're this you're that and so on and so
forth
that you want to take the fight to the
enemy malice
this is why i love you malice it's a
great point i don't know
yeah it's somewhere over here i think
yeah it's over there uh it's a great
point on one hand they're saying get in
their faces
don't let them have an inch blah blah
and then on the other hand they're
saying don't talk to them at all and
pretend they don't exist
and we saw a great example of this when
brian stelter
from cnn he had a panel and they were
freaking out
that venues like tim poole like your
show
joe rogan several others have bigger
audiences of cnn
and people are getting the wrong
information about which they mean
information they don't like
and what are we going to do about this
so their agenda
is basically well let's pretend that
dave's reuben don't exist the tim's pool
don't exist
well that became too hard your audience
is too big your social media following
is too big
now it's like well an individual level
maybe we'll starve him out of guests
you have no shortage of people idiots
from brooklyn you know dressing like
question
banging down your door to try to get on
this show so that's not really going to
work
but it shows their desperation the fact
they're running out of ideas
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell